il est l'heure de vous parler d'un
smartphone hypra cool et surtout un
smartphone que je vais vous offrir
c'est celui là c'est le samsung galaxy
cette folle de 2 le samsung galaxy z sol
de 2 qui est le smartphone pliable ou
clients comme vous voulez de samsung que
vous pouvez venir ouvrir très facilement
et vous avez accès à tout intérieur de
votre smartphone vous avez tout votre
contenu dans votre smartphone qu'ils
plient c'est un smartphone d'un nouveau
genre et surtout un smartphone que je
vous offre enfin que nous offre qu'on
vous offre avec samsung parce qu'à
quelques temps samsung est venu me voir
en disant hey monsieur brun si on
offrait samsung galaxy cette folle de 2
à l'aune des followers lit mais bien sûr
bien évidemment qu'on va faire ça c'est
très cool surtout on va pas vous offrir
n'importe quel galaxy z folle de deux
bombes a besoin d'offrir un complètement
customisée parce que oui samsung vous
offre en exclusivité sur son site la
possibilité de venir customiser votre
samsung galaxy cette folle de 2 alors je
vais tout vous montrer comment le
customiser comment le gagner et surtout
je vous donnais bon retour enfin enfin
ce samsung galaxy cette folle de deux et
vous allez voir c'est un smartphone qui
est très atypique vous en douterez
calais point très positif quelques fois
encore négatif mais qui par contre en
fut une vraie belle vision de l'avenir
de ce que vont être les smartphones dans
l'avenir et notamment on les voulait ce
parfum qui explique cette aujourd'hui
une vidéo qui est réalisé en partenariat
avec clic clic et une assurance d'un
nouveau genre qui est 100% digitale
clics vous permet d'assurer vos produits
tech mais pas que notamment un samsung
galaxy z folle de 2 comme celui-là coûte
un peu d'argent on est un peu plus de
2000 euros autant vous dire que ça a un
vrai sens de venir l'assuré il vient
donc assuré ici mon smartphone contre le
vol mais également contre les dommages
par casse ou par liquide dans la limite
de 1 vol et de dommages par les
inscriptions se font sur le site de
clips point fr puis vous pilotez tous
directement depuis votre application que
ce soit la signature du contrat ou
encore la déclaration de sinistre tout
se fait directement depuis votre
application points positifs
vun activer votre assurance que lorsque
vous en avez besoin
par exemple en ce moment on est en
confinement je pense que ça vous aura
pas échappé
eh bien vous n'allez pas forcément
sortir à l'extérieur avec votre
smartphone vous allez donc minimiser les
risques liés au vol est liée à la casse
donc en restant à domicile vous allez
pouvoir désactiver votre assurance et
lorsque vous allez ressortir chez vous
et bien
vous pourrez décidé de réactiver votre
assurance pour faire courir toutes les
protections vous n'avez donc absolument
pas besoin de l'activer en permanence
vous n'allez donc réactiver votre
assurance que lorsque vous en avez
réellement besoin vous avez la seule
obligation d'avoir votre assurance
active et 90 jours par an ça peut être
par exemple deux jours par ci quatre
jours par là pour un minimum de 90 jours
sur 12 mois autant vous dire que c'est
assez peu vous avez pas moins de 180
centres de réparation agréé par clic
dans la plupart des cas vos smartphones
seront réparés sous moins de 24 heures
si c'est pas le cas vous prêtera un
smartphone de valeur équivalente
je vous ai déjà par le clic dans une
précédente vidéo je vous ai mis un lien
en bas dans la description pour tout
savoir sur les services de clic et vous
pouvez assurer bien plus que votre
smartphone
ça peut être le casque une console votre
vélo ou bien encore une tablette
je vous invite à venir assurer tous les
produits qui vous tiennent à coeur sur
clint point fr avant que je vous montre
comment venir customiser comment venir
personnaliser le smartphone que vous
allez gagner ou vous pouvez également
acheter avec un code de propos mais ça
dans quelques instants nous en parler de
vous inviter à venir vous abonner en
cliquant sur le petit bouton vous avez
là le petit bouton
si les rouges si vous n'êtes pas abonné
vous invite à venir actionner la cloche
pour intensifier dès qu une prochaine
vidéo arrivera si vous débarquez de mars
et vous ne savez pas que samsung a sorti
des smartphones qui se plaît laissez-moi
vous présenter ce produit
ici vous avez le petit écran petit écran
oui mais de 6,2 pouces petit écran
surtout très long écran avec un format
qui est très particulier si si c'est du
25 9e
c'est de l'android vous avez vos
différentes applications pour venir les
utiliser facilement vous déplacez
choisir celles que vous voulez pour
venir visionner du contenu pour vous
amuser
bon c'est très simple ça marche très
très bien mais la belle surprise est à
l'intérieur puisque oui ici à
l'intérieur vous retrouvez votre très
grand écran vous êtes sûre du 7,6 pouces
c'est particulier c'est beau c'est très
bien et surtout vous avez ici une toute
nouvelle charnière qui était revenue
travailler avec des petits brossette à
l'intérieur pour éviter qu'elles les
cochonneries et ne viennent se glisser à
l'intérieur d'autres mécanismes ce
serait comme un peu ballot vous avez si
un triptyque de 12 mégapixels je vous
montre le résultat dans quelques
instants un très joli produit un peu
épais mais qui montre surtout un certain
avenir du smartphone du côté des
smartphones qui se plie moi j'aime
beaucoup et rien que pour ça ce
smartphone je ne peux que vous le
recommander alors calme-toi monsieur re
ce smartphone il n'est pas non plus
destiné à tout le monde parce qu'il
coûte quand même 2020 euros on
plus de 2000 euros pour un smartphone
mais on est dans les technologies
innovantes dans un format qui est tout
nouveau qui est très particulier donc
forcément ça ça vient se payer je vous
remet sur le site de samsung parce que
pour le coup ils ont fait un truc est
vachement bien pour boyer venir le
personnaliser regardez on a quelques
photos de voir à quoi ils peuvent venir
ressembler en revenant personnaliser
l'expérience et en revenant notamment
personnaliser la charnière ça c'est
super sympa très original avec samsung
on vous offre 10 % de remise pour venir
personnaliser votre samsung galaxy z
folle de deux ça c'est très cool le
connaît dans la description plus le lien
les jeunes qui coup d'oeil vous
arriverez sur cette page
ici on va dire qu'on n'a pas de reprise
ont choisi de la nôtre est folle de deux
ans choisit la couleur soit le mystique
bronze soit le music black et on se tord
bien personnaliser la charnière
métallique silver metallic gold metallic
blue metallic raid ou choisissez ce que
vous voulez vous pouvez choisir aussi de
ne pas venir la personnaliser pour avoir
une charnière un peu classique moi je
trouve ça cool de venir à personnaliser
par exemple vous mettez allez on va se
dire le petit gold choisissez la mémoire
2020 euros collectivités 5 g c'est un
smartphone qui en 5 g grâce au stand
dragonne 865 plus ça c'est très cool
vous choisissez si vous voulez samsun
caire ou pas ici on a une assurance
kling n'ont pas besoin de samsung coeur
et vous avez ici un total vous cliquez
sur continuer en plus ils vous offrent
des galaxies boys magnifique et vous
venez rajouter ici le code promotionnel
that folle de tirer grrrr je voulais me
dans la description sera plus facile à
retenir vous cliquez sur appliquée et là
badaboum magie vous faites des économies
votre téléphone tombe à 1818 euros ça
reste une somme mais c'est quand même
beaucoup moins cher parce que oui bien
évidemment on vous en offre e 1 il y en
aura pas deux a gagné gagnera justin
c'est déjà très très cool mais si vous
le voulez absolument et que vous n'êtes
pas sûr de gagner
j'habite à passer par les liens d'un
description pour vous faire plaisir un
tarif préférentiel et en plus
personnalisés à la fin de la vidéo je
vous expliquerai comment venir gagner
votre samsung galaxy z fold deux très
facilement vous allez voir rien de bien
compliqué laissez moi maintenant vous
donner mon retour sur ce smartphone a
effectivement c'est un smartphone
d'exception c'est un smartphone tout
particulier son smartphone qui se
plissent est le seul à avoir ce format
là aujourd'hui pour venir se plier et ce
samsung galaxy z paul ii 2 il est très
particulier il offre une expérience qui
est inédite une expérience
différenciante par rapport à ce qu'on
peut retrouver sur l'ensemble des
smartphones du marché actuel je vais
commencer par vous dire ce que j'ai sur
son smartphone et quels sont les points
positifs
déjà ce que j'aime par rapport à la
version précédente et vous avez un très
grand écran à l'avant qui vous servira
vraiment pour venir naviguer pour
regarder un article dans votre journal
très facilement vous pouvez aussi bien
venir le lire comme ça ou alors décidé
d'ouvrir votre smartphone pour continuer
la lecture et à l'intérieur et ça pour
moi c'est un des points mais vraiment
mais vraiment très très très important
vous avez une vraie qualité de lecture
et ça c'est très rare aujourd'hui dans
un smartphone ce grand écran vous permet
de ne pas vous fatiguer les yeux et de
profiter vraiment d'une expérience mais
complètement maximisée en plus de ça la
qualité des écrans aussi bien intérieurs
extérieurs sont vraiment optimisé très
bonne luminosité gestion des couleurs
qui est magnifique on est sur l'eau
l'aide d'un côté comme de l'autre
l'expérience est irréprochable une fois
de plus samsung montre les muscles et le
fait extrêmement bien que je vais aimer
ici c'est l'expérience avec un écran
avec un taux de rafraîchissement de 120
hertz un très très grand écran qui vous
offrira une expérience mais complètement
exceptionnelle pour tous vos jeux dans
la mesure où vos jeux sont compatibles
avec la taille de cet écran parce que
oui et c'est un défaut du smartphone
face à un défaut séparément à défaut
mais c'est une limite c'est que toutes
les applications ne sont pas optimisés
vous voyez ici là sur les bandes en haut
et en bas tout le développeur non pas
optimiser leur jeu vous retrouver avec
des espèce d'aberration et ça ça vient
petit peu gâché l'expérience quand même
ça c'est la limite des nouveautés comme
ce smartphone là comme on l'est sur un
écran qui est très particulier on sent
vraiment des sentiers battus on sort de
ce qu'on peut retrouver avec des ratios
un petit peu standard avec des
révolutions standard et bien forcément
les développeurs n'ont pas adapté leur
jeu spécialement pour un samsung galaxy
z folle de 2 qui reste malgré tout un
smartphone de niche un smartphone très
très haut de gamme que toujours un
public ne m'a pas venir acheter pourquoi
aujourd'hui des développeurs des récents
tirs des versions 100 % adapté irait
travailler vraiment pour adapter leurs
applications pour ce smartphone il ya
assez peu de raison c'est la raison pour
laquelle vous retrouver certaines fois
des choses un peu peur des rentes
je vous ai montré des jeux mais même une
application comme instagram n'est
absolument pas optimisée autant sur mon
petit écran ça conviendra alors je vous
cache pas que ce format long donc si on
a peu près sur instagram
mais ce qu'on veut surtout c'est en
profiter avec un très grand écran et là
tout de suite ça devient complètement
imbuvable et ça c'est surprenant qu'une
boîte comme instagram n'ai rien fait
pour s'adapter à ce smartphone on a des
bons côtés qui sont absolument horrible
très horrible et l'expérience n'est pas
du tout optimisé qui dit grand écran
multitâche personnellement le multitâche
ne l'utilisent pas on peut le faire si
on souhaite mais pour moi ya pas trop
d'intérêt là dessus si je veux un grand
écran c'est justement pour profiter
d'une meilleure qualité d'affichage de
l'affichage beaucoup plus grand et
beaucoup plus confortable c'est pas pour
venir séparer mon écran en deux on peut
venir me faire du multitâche jusqu'à
trois applications n'est globalement
pour moi il ya très très peu d'intérêt
je vois pas l'intérêt d'aller regarder
une vidéo en euros ils allaient tout est
en dessous d'aller sur instagram ou de
travailler de faire ces mails n'ont
cependant se disent très soit je regarde
une vidéo soit je fais mes e-mails la
seule chose que j'accepterai c'est de
mettre de la musique et pouvoir
travailler au delà de ça le reste des
usages pour moi donc multitâche j'y
crois pas trop
en tout cas pas trop déçu ça m'intéresse
pas trop mais c'est surtout un
smartphone qui est extrêmement
performant samsung nous a mis le
meilleur processeur actuel de sucer le
sang dragons 865 plus compatibles 5 j'ai
donc ce smartphone est prêt pour la 5g
vous avez 12 ian ram 256 giga de
stockage et une batterie de 4500
millions terreur qui me permettra de
tenir un jour sans aucun problème
un jour et demi peut-être deux jours en
fonction de vous et de vos usages
on pourra regretter si d'avoir un bloc
de charge uniquement de 25 watts bon
voilà pas très grave
maintenant la limite du produit c'est
son format ça c'est quand même un peu
dommage je vous montre par exemple sur
netflix
on se dit qu'un grand écran comme ça on
va venir l'utiliser pour regarder des
films avant tout pour vraiment un très
très bon confort et là il ya un truc qui
marche absolument pas qui vise à se se
retrouve avec des grandes bandes noires
en haut et en bas sur les flics et si on
veut profiter de la meilleure expérience
paf
eh bien on vient de perdre beaucoup mais
beaucoup de contenu et ça ça c'est
vraiment dommage
il a même manière si jared et des vidéos
sur youtube et bien regardez je me
retrouve avec un format qui est très
très très particulier là avec youtube on
parvient à l'agrandir je reste sur ce
format ça veut dire que j'ai des grandes
bordure haut et en bas je peux et
strictement rien faire et je vais quand
même pas me regarder les vidéos sur cet
écran là ça n'a absolument aucun sens
voyez les grands bonheurs côté je peux
venir agrandir mais je perds tellement
que vous voyez c'est dommage qu'on peut
se dire je vais mettre en mode flex
comme ça plie pour regarder mon contenu
là mais c'est pas du tout non plus
complètement optimisé ont perdu tissé
tout l'intérêt qu'on avait avec un grand
écran pour avoir une belle qualité de
visionnage avec des grandes bordure en
haut en bas en mode vie
oh et ça c'est dommage parce que ça fait
partie des très gros usage aujourd'hui
je ne vois pas comment on peut venir
améliorer ça sent que samsung vient de
changer
le ratio d'affichage de ses smartphones
une vidéo sera du 16/9 on pourra voir
des films en vain de vienne mais avec
des écrans 25 9 jan c'est strictement
impossible de couper à ces grandes
bandes noires c'est strictement
impossible donc ça c'est très très
bizarre effet la limite du produit à
côté de ça on a une très très belle
qualité d'affichage
on a des haut parleurs stéréo qui sont
aussi vraiment bien et qui vont
complètement venir maximiser
l'expérience pour venir regarder vous
avez du bluetooth pour venir vous
connecter avec votre casque sans fil ou
avec vos galaxie bonsai m'enfin c'est
vraiment un excellent smartphone que
j'adore il coûte cher
certes une fois de plus mais parce qu'on
est dans le très haut de gamme dark
chose de très particulier c'est pas
vraiment un point négatif mais il faut
le signaler vous avez une pliure qui est
apparente si vous la voyez bien sûr le
dessus l'a7 pliure est là parce que
forcément un écran qui se plie donc
forcément la pliure est apparente on
oublie très facilement il n'y a rien de
bien dérangeant sous le doigt c'est très
doux on assemble ça ne pose absolument
aucun problème il ya un autre point
connais tu sais que c'est un smartphone
qui de par cette nouvelle technologie
n'est absolument pas certifiées et
certifiable donc pas résistante à l'eau
et à la poussière
d'où l'intérêt de venir l'assuré je
passe très très rapidement sur les
photos prises avec ce smartphone parce
qu'ici vous avez un triptyque qui marche
très bien
trois fois 12 mégapixels on va retrouver
les mêmes caméras qu'on avait dans les
générations de l'année dernière et ça
marche très très bien que sa censure
capteur principal sur l' ultra
grand-angle et lorsqu'on vient zoomer se
rapprocher leurs plus on se rapproche
d'un moment on va papa d'un petit peu en
qualité mais dans l'absolu le boulot est
vraiment bien fait très très très belle
maîtrise de la part de samsung et même
la caméra de celle fille à l'intérieur
des smartphones marchera très bien c'est
donc un smartphone que je vous offre
qu'on vous offre avec samsung pour venir
participer c'est très facile vous avez
un lien en bas dans la description il
suffit de venir
cliquez dessus et vous allez pouvoir
participer à un petit jeu qui vous
permettra d'être peut-être tirés au sort
pour gagner votre samsung galaxy z folle
de deux complètement personnalisée à
vous me dire vous maintenant ce que vous
en pensez de ce smartphone qu'est ce que
vous pensez de ce format est ce que vous
trouvez intéressant est ce que vous
trouvez pertinents est ce que vous voyez
les usages est ce que vous pensez qu'ils
aient répondu aux usages que ce qu'on a
un ego smartphone un peu plus
traditionnel avec une forme en tout cas
un peu plus classique et est ce que vous
entre apercevez avec cette forme de
smartphone avec des écrans qui se plie
le smartphone du futur marc m'a tout ça
en bas en commentaire bonne chance pour
le jeu et à très bientôt
de labour ciao
[Musique]
à